so by now it's pretty much all but
confirmed that Avengers four is going to
involve time travel somehow this first
started when we saw leaked photos of
Iron Man Captain America the Hulk and
ant-man and what looked like the
original Avengers movie in the Battle of
New York and not to mention that Tony
Stark looks a little bit older in the
leaked photos Captain America is wearing
his og uniform from the first Avengers
movie and they all have these little
devices on their hands
and now the ant-man and the wasp came
out we know that there is a time vortex
inside the quantum realm don't worry
that does not give any spoilers away for
a man and the wasp so calm down not to
mention Kevin Feige said that there
would be time jumping in Avengers 4 so
we know there's been a lot of talk
around going back in time in Avengers 4
and what all could happen and most of it
is regarding the Infinity stones or
forging an Infinity Gauntlet or warning
the past Avengers what's going to happen
in the future and that's all very
exciting and very important but I think
we're overlooking a key element here and
that is Loki we have seen this leaked
photo that shows a younger Loki in
handcuffs now this is obviously back in
time it's around the ending events of
the first Avengers movie where Thor is
about to take Loki back to Asgard but
what's interesting is these photos show
a scene that we didn't see in the first
Avengers movie this shows for shield
body guards surrounding Loki which we
never saw in the movie the only thing we
saw was Thor taking him back to Asgard
and it's highly believed that Tony Stark
is actually in disguise as one of those
bodyguards so this appears to be a new
scene which would take place in Avengers
4 and to me what would make the most
sense for the Avengers going back in
time would be for them to try and
convince Loki to betray Thanos early on
and I can picture it all in my head
pretty clearly they grabbed Loki right
before Thor takes them back to Asgard
and they explain the situation they
explain all of the events that just took
place in infinity war they explain that
a nose actually gets all the Infinity
stones he succeeds and half of the
universe gets wiped away from existence
and not to mention Loki dies and he
doesn't die from the snap
Thanos actually kills him so they're
going to present this to Loki because
right now
Loki works for Thanos he may have just
failed and been caught but he still
works for Thanos so it would make sense
for them to try and convince him to
betray Thanos and then let him go so he
can make some sort of attempt to try and
stop vanos before he gets all of the
Infinity stones a strategy that could
very well work but here's the problem
this is younger Loki his mind and his
heart are still the same as they were
when he was the villain remember after
the first Avengers movie came Thor to
the dark world in which he faked his own
death so he could take over the throne
which he did he put Odin under a spell
cast him off into earth somewhere and
took over Asgard pretending to be Odin
so this is still a very mischievous and
evil Loki so there's no real way of
knowing if floki will actually help them
or not the thought of his own death
might be enough to make him turn but who
knows this is Loki the god of mischief
and again it's in the past so it's a
younger Loki so I'm sure his brain is
thinking of ways that he can somehow
betray the Avengers and use this
knowledge to his advantage to gain favor
with Thanos because if they tell Loki
that Thanos kills him because he fails
Thanos and then tries to betray him then
Loki could just not betray Thanos and if
the Avengers let him go back to Thanos
he could tell fan OHS everything that he
was just told and this would probably
make up for his failure in New York and
at this point in time Loki probably
wants to be on the good side of Thanos
more than he does his brother in the
Avengers after all he did just try to
take over the earth and kill all the
Avengers and not to mention that in one
of the plot leaks that we received it
says that at some point in time when the
Avengers are going back in time and
trying to do their own thing and click
their own Infinity stones
Thanos finds out somehow how do you
think he finds out to me this lines up
perfectly and makes perfect sense
so if Loki is put in this situation and
again
it's the past younger Loki not the
current one that everybody loves what do
you think he'll do I want to know your
thoughts opinions theories and keep in
mind that we're dealing with the past
young Loki let me know in the comments
below and of course be sure to like this
video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date
with everything related to Avengers 4
Marvel DC and everything superhero thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you